[Music]
hey everybody its charlie I've been
getting a lot of requests to do a video
for Godspeed to the flash season 4 flash
war and God speed in the comics because
he's just become a much bigger character
right now so we'll talk about flash war
stuff first then I'll talk about flash
TV show
he's been around this whole time but
ever since Wally West and Barry took him
down at the beginning of flash rebirth
he's been chilling in iron Heights
prison so he's back out now and the
really big thing is that they canonized
him as a member of the flash family
meaning they want you to think that he's
a good character because even though
reverse-flash
is a flash he's not part of the flash
family usually you only give that term
to people who are good so if you're
finding me for the first time be sure to
subscribe to get all the DC videos
there's also some other big news that
they just announced that I'll talk about
at the end of the video too if there is
a new round of that blast ring giveaway
all you have to do to enter that just be
a subscriber and leave a plashy related
comment on the video so big thing coming
up flash war most of you have probably
heard of it even if you're not following
along in the comics but what it is is
essentially it's the entire flash family
all the good Flash's fighting against
each other so Josh Williamson who's been
writing the comic for a long time has
been killing it he's been doing an
awesome job but when he announced flash
more people were like I'm really excited
but I have no freaking idea why Wally
West would be fighting with the other
flashes like the whole pitch is that it
would decide who was the fastest flash
of them all
it was ginger Wally West holding a
couple of his costumes one of his yellow
costume when he was still Kid Flash than
the red costume that he wore after he
became the main version of the flash
right after crisis on Infinite Earths
the costume he's wearing now is sort of
like his post rebirth costume a red
version of the Kid Flash costume just to
differentiate him from Barry they also
have a different emblem Wally's is
silver and Barry's has the gold on it
what about godspeed though you're like
why is he a good flash now I thought he
was evil he tried to kill Barry so if he
dropped off after that first god speed
run when Barry in african-american Kid
Flash Wally West took him down they
threw him in iron Heights prison red
around the time Barry was infused with
the negative Speed Force and became
negative flash for a little while he
also messed up big-time
as a CSI so his punishment he had to
serve a tour of duty working out of iron
Heights prison so while he was in there
they had this big rogues run but God
speed was a part of that and he very
briefly became part of the Rogues but
the things they've been teasing is that
because he and Barry had been longtime
friends even before Barry got the Speed
Force for the first time they had this
sort of Anakin Skywalker obi-wan Kenobi
relationship Barry being the obi-wan
Kenobi like they're really close friends
but God speed just went totally off the
rails during rebirth so in the lead up
to flash war we learned that Gorilla
Grodd has been manipulating speedsters
in the Speed Force itself to try and
heal himself he's slowly dying and he
feels like getting the Speed Force is
the only thing that can save him
so he's been using evil speedsters to
manipulate the chessboard from afar
through the black hole organization so
if you've read even a little bit of
flash rebirth black hole is just an evil
organization that's sort of swirling in
the background with people that the
flash fights every once in a while they
were much bigger part of that first god
speed run now we know that it was
actually Gorilla Grodd in the early
stages of his plan to steal the Speed
Force from Barry Allen normally the
flash family would be enough to take
down Gorilla Grodd but because Grodd has
so many evil speedsters working for him
they're able to siphon the Speed Force
off of Barry so powerless he turns to
the flash family for a little bit of
help but he also turns to god speed his
old bread who jokes with him about his
addiction to the Speed Force because
Barry is obsessed with getting it back
just as obsessed as Grodd is in getting
the Speed Force
so Barry not totally thinking clearly
God speed explains sort of what he's
been doing this whole time on the side
like he's been locked up in prison but
he actually says that he was trying to
hunt down and learn about black hole so
he actually was doing a lot of good
things so Godspeed Kid Flash
Avery ho who's the flash of China if you
guys haven't been reading the comics in
Barry Allen team up to go against Grodd
in his evil speedsters basically me
Narayan in multi-plex who's been infused
with the Speed Force but we still
haven't gotten to flash war yet Barry
has stolen garage special lightning rod
that's the critical piece in his plan to
take the Speed Force back thinking that
if he can reverse the effects he can get
his speedforce abilities back but you
know naturally everybody tells him not
to do that so he totally doesn't listen
to them and winds up creating a
situation whereby Grodd is fused with
the Speed Force meaning that he can
telepathically control anybody that's
connected to the Speed Force so here's
where we start to get to the flash war
up at all you have Barry versus the
entire flash family but remember Wally
West is a big part of this too and Grodd
is sort of sitting there pondering the
differences between Barry and Wally like
Barry's a scientist he has a very
scientific deep understanding of the
Speed Force but the really cool thing
about the ginger Wally West is that he
has a very spiritual understanding of
the Speed Force just like a completely
different way of looking at things and
it's mostly a callback to classic Mark
Waid Wally West flash but because the
actual flash war event doesn't start for
about 6 more issues what will probably
happen is is that Wally will be really
pissed off at Barry because of his
addiction to the Speed Force the fact
that he is going off the rails and over
the course of clash war Barry the
scientist will come to have a much more
spiritual connection with the Speed
Force the way that Wally West does so
was just a way to put the ginger Wally
West at the center of a really big flash
event they've been teasing us a lot with
what the future of Wally is going to be
in the DC Universe so the really cool
thing about them bringing god speed back
and making him a much bigger character
and the way they frame him in this story
is that he's sort of like the Red Hood
of the flash family chaotic good
so he's both try to kill members of team
flash like Red Hood tried to kill Batman
for a little while but eventually he
came back to the bat family so god speed
is now technically flash family remains
to be seen how they're gonna use the
character after a flash war is done but
I sense it's gonna continue to be in a
Red Hood style way where sometimes he
does really underhanded shady stuff
sometimes he helps the team out but you
see the beauty in doing that to his
character because like Red Hood over in
the Batman family probably one of the
best twists on a character in a long
long time so the flash family just kind
of needs somebody like that
somebody who can be a real badass really
hardcore it could be way more complex
than like Wally or Barry who have to be
pretty good characters most of the time
like it would be weird if while they
turned evil or Barry turned evil you
almost would
believe it but I know a lot of you are
also asking about God speed on the flash
TV show so here's actually something
that's really interesting if you guys
remember last time around this year we
started to get a lot more Sabbat are in
broad daylight on the flash TV show he
had a very Godspeed looking type of suit
just super hardcore super intense
compared to the main version of the
flash
this is how much more popular the flash
was at that time than it is today right
now so even though the flash TV show
wasn't doing Godspeed the visual style
the mere idea of it was just crazy
popular so they would be stupid not to
do god speed at some point in the future
but the problem that they have is that
they'd have to introduce August Hart is
sort of this new character that comes to
town in in the flash comics during
Reaper they sort of ret conned him into
the story
so when rebirth started they sort of
altered the timeline in August had been
friends with Barry working at the police
station for a long long time way before
he ever got his speed force abilities so
he's one of the few people that knew
Barry really well before he became the
flash which is why they're able to still
be friends after godspeed became god
speed and started killing all these
other speedsters the TV show has already
kind of done their version of flash
points so they would have to find some
way of introducing the august heart
character in a future season and do it
in a way that didn't feel like they were
trying to just shoehorn the character in
because he's so popular but right now it
seems like they're mostly teeing up the
idea of what's gonna be happening down
the road with future versions of the
flash like Barry and irises children
potential Bart Allen and then there's
you know whatever the new version of the
reverse flash is going to look like like
remember during the crossover and wonder
what my face will look like the next
time we meet
so when you think about god speed on the
TV show think of him as having more of
an Anakin Skywalker arc like this
promise person with a lot of potential
that falls from grace but then you know
eventually turns into more of a Red Hood
character as per this new flash war
story so all really cool stuff obviously
the flash TV shows on break right now
but just leave all your requests for
bonus videos in the comments below the
really big news to is that they hired a
writer for the New Gods movie who is
somebody that's done a lot of heist
movies making me think that the New Gods
movie is going to be a heist movie led
by mr. miracle which is probably the
best thing that they could have gone for
so mr. miracle stealing something from
apocalypse breaking in somehow feels
like a pretty easy slam dunk from a
story structure standpoint but a lot of
it just depends on what it feels like
what the tone is what it looks like so
it's gonna be a while before we get more
details on that but they just announced
the movie then literally while I was
making this video they now
they had hired a writer so we'll
probably get some more news at Comic Con
in the Marvel Universe there's all this
infinity war stuff that's happening
they'll be more Deadpool really soon too
so while you wait for everything click
here for the trailer for the next
episode of the flash and click here for
brand-new infinity war I did a Hawkeye
edit of the trailer thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight